[Musique]
bonjour enfin par jour
madame grès regarder par la fenêtre
je vous emmène en week end j'ai du mal à
croire que c'est ma vie que j'ai la
chance de vivre avec toi
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
euroda n'agrège l'écoutent
je passe te prendra cinq heures sauf si
je n'ai pas terminé d'ici là week je
peux conduire non elle est magnifique je
vais acheter pour nos jeunes a tort
christian tu
elle est idéalement situé je vais vous
construire une maison de rêve
arrêtez de parler à mon mari comme si je
n'étais pas là anna vous pouvez
m'appeler madame grès
je devrai d aubert plus souvent
nous sommes suivis
[Musique]
alors quelle nouvelle anna jacques vous
voulez quoi
[Musique]
tu as envie de jouer oui monsieur
question
j'ai juré de te protéger je le ferais tu
ne peux pas m'enfermer dans une cage
j'ai fait la promesse de thé mais
finalement en renonçant à toute autre tu
as couché avec et de te réconforter dans
la détresse
aussi longtemps que nous vivons pourquoi
est ce que tu me défi
parce que je perds tu es beau